iran says it has defended a vietnamese
flagship from being seized in the sea of
oman it says elite revolutionary guard
troops boarded the ship on october 24th
saying the tanker was about to be taken
by the united states the u.s meanwhile
is accusing iran of staging dangerous
maneuvers at sea well joining me now in
the studio is our iran correspondent
dorothy jabari dorissa just explain to
us what's happening here well the
revolutionary guards have now released
this
rather elaborate video that clearly has
been edited uh which shows the
elite forces of the revolution guards
the naval division taking over this oil
tanker
there is communication clearly that we
hear between
the iranian naval forces and what
appears to be
american and naval forces as well
talking to each other warning one
another
about being in dangerous territories and
that they should go on their own way the
iranians say that this happened because
they believed that their oil was going
to be seized by the americans
and now we understand that this is an
operation that the iranians carried out
because they believed that they had to
seize their oil before it was taken this
is not of course the first time that
we've seen these kinds of maneuvers by
the revolutionary guards happening in
this region the interesting thing now is
that this incident happened on october
24th the iranians have waited until now
to release this footage and also the
americans have yet they didn't say
anything when it happened they said they
haven't really acknowledged on their
side what took place according to
accounts from sources
in the united states the government are
saying that they witnessed this incident
taking place
but they did not interfere with the
iranians at the time is there anything
in the timing here doris so like you say
this uh
supposedly happens
on october 24th we're what a week and a
bit on now from that
is there anything in the timing what
kind of message
are people trying to send here
well the iranians are marking uh
november 4th which is tomorrow
they call it the national day of fight
against arrogance it is the anniversary
of the u.s embassy takeover in tehran
which happened
in november of 1979 52 american
diplomats and citizens were held hostage
for 444 days
just after the revolution of february
1979. and
this is seen as a way of iranian media
iranian government and officials trying
to mark that occasion to show their
strength of course when we look at this
footage closely we see that it's been
edited it's narrated with
farsi script
indicating which ships belong to whom
and what is actually taking place as the
video progresses so
and there's music laid over it's very
very well choreographed as we've seen in
the past from the revolutionary guard
media department
so this is seen as a very interesting
timing for the iranians to release this
video and this news now clearly being
sent a message to the americans that uh
they believe to be the stronger force in
the region and that they are not um
scared or frightened by the u.s presence
in the sea of oman as well as in the
strait of hormuz okay dorset jabari
there talking us through those
developments thank you doris sir we'll
keep a close eye on that for you